[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
Barbara
hallweg guten Abend und willkommen alles
sportlicher hat gleich nbert König guten
Abend und das sind die Nachrichtenthemen
dieses
samstags Protestmarsch erreicht
Jerusalem zeusende erinnern an die von
der Hamas entführten Geiseln im Streifen
greift Israel erneut auch den Süden
an schwieriger Neuanfang die Linke will
auf ihrem Parteitag das Kapitel
Wagenknecht endgültig
beenden und Testflug erneut gescheitert
das größte jemals gebaute Raketensystem
explodiert nur wenige Minuten nach dem
Start wir beginnen im gazaastreifen wo
es für Zivilisten offenbar kaum mehr
sichere Orte gibt auch aus dem Süden des
ab gegelten Küstenstreifens werden immer
mehr Tote und Verletzte gemeldet Israels
Armee fordert seit Kriegsbeginn die
Palästinenser im Norden des
Gazastreifens auf in den Süden zu
flüchten und nimmt seit Wochen
insbesondere Gaza Stadt unter Beschuss
die Hamas habe dort
Kommandozentralen doch Israel greift
auch Ziele im Süden an in chanjunes etwa
die Bevölkerung solle sich Richtung
meerr in Sicherheit bringen Dominik
lmeister
berichtet sie graben mit bloßen Händen
suchen nach Überlebenden hananunis im
Süden des Gazastreifens ist nun
verstärkt das Ziel israelischer
Luftangriffe mindestens 26 Menschen
sollen getötet worden sein so die
palästinensische Seite unabhängig
überprüfen lässt sich das nicht sie
haben nichts getan sie haben in ihren
Häusern geschlafen wohin sollen wir
gehen selbst unser zause ist nicht
sicher dabei istunis der
Zufluchtsort Palästinenser doch die
Menschen sollen die zweitgrößte Stadt in
Gazastreifen verlassen so Israels
Militär doch wo sollen sie hin fragen
Sie sich auch aus dem umkämpften Schifer
Krankenhaus in gaserstadt heute Flucht
Richtung Süden unklar ist wer das
veranlasst
hat ich war im Schifer Krankenhaus und
wir wurden von den Israelis aufgefordert
das Krankenhaus zu verlassen ich
verlasse mein Schicksal der Hand
Gottes die Leitung des Krankenhauses hat
uns gebeten heute morgen einen
evakuierungskorridor für die Menschen
einzurichten die das Krankenhaus
verlassen können das haben wir den
ganzen Tag
überkoordiniert in Jerusalem fordern
zeusende Ministerpräsident netanaho zum
Handeln auf bringt die Geisel nach Hause
fordern sie auf ihrem Marsch der in
telaviv gestartet war die Regierung soll
sich für die Freilassung der über30 von
der Hamas entführten
einsetzen Reg kümmert wir wollen dass
die Regierungen weltweit was alle müssen
jetzt zurückkommen alle ohne
Ausnahme Tel Aviv am Abend die
Angehörigen der Geiseln versammeln sich
noch einmal und hoffen auf eine Bewegung
in der
geiselfrage bei der großen
abschlusundgebung in telaviv ist für uns
Michael bewerunge Michael einige
Angehörige hatten eben ein Gespräch mit
zwei Ministern aus dem kriegskabinett
was wurde ihnen gesagt
ja ich stehe hier auf dem Platz vor dem
Verteidigungsministerium wo auch das
kriegskabinett heute abend wieder Tagen
wird die angehöri der Geisen haben in
den Platz der entführten getauft immer
wieder wird ja a Schaf gerufen jetzt
bringt jetzt unsere Leute zurück man
sieht vielleicht im Hintergrund eine
lange Tafel das ist eine
schabbattafel die leer bleibt für die
mehr als 230 Geiseln zeitgleich findet
nur ein paar Meter entfern treen ST
allerdings nur mit einem Minister aus
dem kriegskabinett die
Organisationskomitee der Geisel hatte
gefordert dass auch netan und
Verteidigungsminister Galland sich dem
Gespräch stellen das haben die
verweigert oder auf jedenfalls für den
heutigen Abend und auf morgen verschoben
momentan läuft nur dieses eine Gespräch
es ist noch nicht viel nach draußen
gerungen gedrungen nur dass Ben Minister
aus dem kriegskabinett den Angehörigen
gesagt hat wir müssen weiterin
Druck auf die Geiseln hochhalten damit
die H zu Zugeständnissen bereit ist und
es wurde gesagt dass die Verhandlung zur
Freilassung sehr intensiv laufen auch
wenn noch nichts Neues bekannt worden
bekannt geworden ist den Menschen hier
reicht das natürlich nicht sie fordern
mehr Zugeständnisse dass noch bevor dem
weiteren Verlauf des Krieges die Geiseln
freigelassen werden danke schön für
diese Einschätzung von der
Abschlusskundgebung michael beung war
das aktuelle Information etwa zum Krieg
in Nahost finden Sie jederzeit auch auf
ZDF heute oder auch unter Aktuelles bei
Whatsapp scannen Sie dafür einfach den
angezeigten QR-Code oder abonnieren Sie
uns bei Whatsapp selbst alles was
wichtig ist kurz und kompakt mit Updates
jeweils morgens und
abends bundesinnenministerin fäer hat
den Auftritt eines talibanvertreters in
einer Kölner Moschee als vollkommen
inakzeptabel bezeichnet niemand dürfe
radikalen Islamisten in Deutschland eine
Bühne bieten am Donnerstag hatte abdulbi
Omar aus Afghanistan in der ditip
Moschee in kölnkorweiler vor Muslimen
gesprochen dietip hat sich von der
Veranstaltung inzwischen distanziert das
Auswärtige Amt will klären wie der
talibanvertreter ohne Visum nach
Deutschland einreisen
konnte die Schuldenbremse fürs laufende
und fürs kommende Jahr aussetzen das
fordert spdchefin esken als Grund nennt
sie die fortdauernde krisenhafte
Situation in der Deutschland sich durch
äußere Einflüsse befendee es gehe darum
wieder mehr Spielraum für staatliche
Aufgaben zu schaffen sagte esken den
Zeitungen der Funke Mediengruppe
Unterstützung bekam sie auch vom
Deutschen Gewerkschaftsbund und der
Chefin der Wirtschaftsweisen Monika
Schnitzler die Linke hat harte Zeiten
hinter sich als Folge des Austritts von
Sarah Wagenknecht sie diese Woche die
Auflösung ihrer Fraktion im Bundestag
jetzt soll der Bundesparteitag in
Augsburg endgültig die kauser
Wagenknecht abhaken und zum Aufbruch in
ein neues Kapitel Blasen leicht fällt
das nicht Christiane hübscher hat
mehr der befürchtete Knall kommt vor
wenigen Minuten einer von SAR
wagenknechts Anhängern meldet eine
Kampfkandidatur gegen parteichf
schirdwan als Europas Spitzenkandidat an
beschimpft die Linke und endet mit einem
erklar auf offener Bühne und ich würde
gern sagen ich bin ohne Groll aber die
Zeit hat Spuren hinterlassen man sieht
mir das an deswegen trete ich heute aus
der Partei aus bis dahin war dieser
Parteitag erstaunlich geräuschlos
verlaufen linke Promis wie Gregor Gesi
fehlen in Augsburg Fraktionschef Bar
findet klare Worte über die Krise der
Linken die Liquidation der
Bundestagsfraktion ist eine gewaltige
Niederlage ich will auch klar sagen die
Verantwortung dafür tragen V zu aller
die abordnen die die Partei verlassen
haben kaum jemand hier spricht den Namen
Wagenknecht aus Neuanfang heißt die
Losung doch selbst dem einzig linken
Ministerpräsidenten will heute keine
echte mutmachrede gelingen die Umfragen
unter 5% in Hessen flog die Partei
zuletzt aus dem Landtag deswegen habe
ich Angst davor dass wir aus anderen
Parlamenten auch noch uns verabschieden
und jeder denkt na ja da kommt ja
vielleicht was Neues oder was
anderesin sich zum Neustart ein
feuerrotes neues Logo und spricht von
700 Neueintritten seit der Wagenknecht
Abspaltung lasst uns offen schonungslos
und vor allem solidarisch über unsere
Defizite reden nicht mit dem Ziel
innerparteilicher Geländegewinne sondern
mit dem Ziel unsere linke wieder stark
zu machen nun wird auch ihr Auftritt mit
Spannung erwartet die Umwelt und
Menschenrechtsaktivistin Carola Rakete
stellt sich gleich zur Wahl als zweite
Spitzenkandidatin für Europa real
Schumacher in Augsburg turbulenter
Parteitag in welcher Verfassung ist die
Linke kann da ein Aufbruch
gelingen tja die Krise diszipliniert
zuallererst der parteitach demonstriert
Geschlossenheit gegen den drohenden
Zerfall das Kapitel Wagenknecht erklärt
der Vorstand für beendet aber so einfach
ist es natürlich nicht mit den Folgen
dieser spektakulären Trennung wird die
Länge die Linke noch lange zu kämpfen
haben der Bedeutungsverlust im Bundestag
ist enorm weitere aus und Übertritte
drohen und dazu die alles entscheidende
Frage wie die Linke den Konkurrenzkampf
mit der
wagenknechtpartei bestehen kann ob der
Aufbruch tatsächlich gelingt entscheidet
sich 2024 bei 3 ostdeutschen
Landtagswahlen will die Linke mit
sozialer Bürgernähe Punkten und mit dem
oberrealo Bodo ramelo der Ordnung in die
Migration bringen will und davor schon
im Juni bei der Europawahl mit der
gerade gewählten aber durchaus nicht
unumstrittenen seenotretterin und
klimaaktivistin Carola Rakete
kontroversese Positionen in dieser Krise
die Linke ist auf der Suche nach sich
selbst und nach ihrem künftigen Kurs
danke nach Augsburg Ralf
schummacher harsche Kritik am
Bundeskanzler kam heute aus den eigenen
Reihen von der SPD Jugend die
Jungsozialisten zeigten sich auf ihrem
Bundeskongress wütend und enttäuscht vom
Kurs des Kanzlers vor allem von der
Migrationspolitik die ihnen zu weit geht
Olaf Scholz hatte abgesagt spdchefin
sasja esken versuchte Vorort die Wogen
zu glätten Fabian
kölller er will den jung Sozialisten
wieder Strahlkraft verleihen Philip
Türmer neugewählter JUSO Vorsitzender
der 27-Jährige macht in Braunschweig auf
dem Bundeskongress immer wieder auch
gegen die eigene parteimobil fordert
Olaf Scholz auf endlich aus der Deckung
zu kommen wirben nicht der Kanzler steht
in der Mitte und moderiert nur statt der
Ampel einen klaren sozialdemokratischen
Kurs zu geben im Ergebnis heißt das
Stillstand bzw es passiert viel zu wenig
vor allen Dingen angesichts der
aktuellen krisenhaften Situation die
jusus sind wütend auf die ampelregierung
auf die Migrationspolitik auf die vielen
Berliner Kompromisse der Wind soll
wieder rauer Richtung Hauptstadt Wehen
das ist das Signal was sie senden wir
wollen die SPD antreiben undtreiben das
heißt natürlich auch dass wir
kritisieren dass wir hart mit ih ins
Gericht gehen Kurswechsel wir sehen die
Gefahr von rechts und wir brauchen echte
linke Lösungen der Kanzler selbst fehlt
es sind andere aus der spdspitze die
hier beim Nachwuchs die
Regierungspolitik verteidigen Dinge
gerade rücken wir müssen endlich im
großen Stil abschieben dieser Satz von
Scholz in einem Interview erzürnt viele
im Saal aber wenn man das ganze
Interview des Kanzlers liest dann kann
man den ganzheitlichen Ansatz der
Migrationspolitik der Ampel schon
erkennen die Sprache die Sprache ist
unser Problem
mit neuen starken jusus wird der Druck
innerhalb der SPD größer spätestens
Anfang Dezember wird die Jugend auch auf
den Kanzler treffen dann ist SPD
Bundesparteitag zum Tarifkonflikt bei
der Bahn da hat die
lockführergewerkschaft GDL ja zu einer
Urabstimmung über weitere Streiks
aufgerufen das kritisierte jetzt die
Deutsche Bahn als befremdlich und völlig
irrational die GDL suche den Konflikt
und seit zu kooper tion nicht in der
Lage verhandelt wird erst seit einer
Woche ab 75% ja bei der Urabstimmung
drohen längere
Streiks Spaniens Regierungschef Sanchez
war vorgestern vom Parlament
wiedergewählt worden doch die Proteste
wegen seines Deals mit zwei
katalanischen
separatistenparteien reißen nicht ab
rund 170 000 Menschen gingen nach
Behördenangaben in Madrid auf die Straße
skandierten Parolen wie Sanchez ins
Gefängnis und Verräter Sanchez brauchte
die katalanischen Stimmen für seine
Wiederwahl im Gegenzug sagte er ein
Amnestiegesetz für katalanische
Separatisten
zu antisemitische Inhalte auf der
Internetplattform x haben heftige Kritik
ausgelöst auch an Betreiber Elon Musk
der Milliardär hatte einem Beitrag
zugestimmt in dem behauptet wurde
jüdische Menschen würden Hass gegen
weiße schüren das Weiße Haus verurteilte
das als abscheuliche Förderung von
antisemitischem und rassistischem Hass
außerdem stoppten mehrere große
Unternehmen wie IBM Ihre Werbung bei X
nachdem ihre Anzeigen neben
nazibeiträgen und antisemitischen
Äußerungen
auftauchten auch in anderer Hinsicht
lief der Tag heute nicht perfekt für
Elon Musk es geht um seine
Weltraumrakete Starship ein erster
unbemannter Teststart in Texas war schon
im April schief gegangen auch diesmal
explodierten sowohl Rakete als auch
antriebsstufe wegen der gesammelten
Erfahrung sprach das Unternehmen
trotzdem von einem unglaublich
erfolgreichen Tag Alisa
jung es ist noch früh am Morgen im Süden
von Texas die Sonne geht gerade
auf diese Bilder sind einfach
unglaublich wir könnten uns keinen
schöneren Tag für diesen Test wünschen
hört man aus dem Kontrollraum es ist der
zweite Versuch von Elon musks Raumfahrt
und Unternehmen SpaceX um das größte
gebaute Raketensystem der Geschichte ins
All zu schicken großer Jubel beim
erfolgreichen Start von Starship anfangs
sieht alles perfekt aus beide
Raketenstufen trennen sich doch dann
explodiert erst die antriebsstufe und
später auch die Rakete das Signal reißt
ab Musk und sein Team werten den
missglückten Versuch trotzdem als Erfolg
Starship flog weiter als beim ersten
Test
das tolle heute ist der erfolgreiche
Start das Trennen war wunderbar genau
was wir
wollten und auch der Chef der NASA
gratuliert bei Ex der heutige Test ist
eine Möglichkeit zu lernen und dann
wieder zu fliegen die NASA kooperiert
mit SpaceX für alle wäre ein Erfolg
wichtig die Kosten würden massiv sinken
Raumschiff und Rakete sollen wieder
verwendbar
sein sie könnten massiv den Preis
reduzieren um ein Kilo ins All zu
schicken
von 25000
bis000 auf 200 bis
500 wenn es einmal glückt soll Starship
künftig viele Tonnen transportieren und
mehrere Menschen ins All fliegen können
Sie träumen weiter von Missionen zu Mars
und
Mond nach Wochen extremer Trockenheit
und Hitze wüten in Brasilien die
schlimmsten Waldbrände seit mehr als 20
Jahren betroffen ist vor allem das
weltberühmte Naturschutz Gebiet Pantanal
in dem Feuchtgebiet sind bereits riesige
Flächen verbrannt in Brasilien ist
gerade erst Frühling und so werden in
den nächsten Wochen weitere
Temperaturrekorde
erwartet jetzt du Norbert heute abend
Deutschland Türkei ein Fußballfest
ziemlich sicher und vor allen Dingen
hoffen wir dass es gariert ist mit ein
paar Toren das wäre doch schön für den
Bundestrainer wird es unabhängig vom
Ergebnis ein besonderer Abend der Test
gegen die Türkei in Berlin ist das erste
Heimspiel für Julian nagelsmann als Chef
der
Fußballnationalmannschaft der Männer
Thomas gulski im Olympiastadion das wird
aber höchstens ein halbes Heimspiel
oder ja bestenfalls atmosphärisch wird
es eher ein Auswärtsspiel das deutet
sich jetzt schon an anderthalb Stunden
vor dem Spiel das Stadion fast 75 000
Zuschauer knapp es ist ausverkauft und
man kann davon ausgehen dass mehr als
die Hälfte türkische Fans sein werden
ich rechne mit bis zu
und die für eine atmosre entfen könen
das haben die Bayern gerade in Istanbul
erfahren ist eineinhalb Stunden vor
anfff schon klar wer im deutschen Tor
stehen
wird die aktuelle Nummer 1 Mark andre
tegen mit Sicherheit nicht erst
abgereist wegen Rückenschmerzen ich
rechne mit Kevin tra dem Frankfurter der
dann zu seinem aten Länderspiel käme für
den deutschen Kapitän gündan wird es ein
ganz besonderes Spiel er spielt erstmals
gegen das Heimatland seiner Eltern also
mixed emotions wie bei so vielen hier
heute im Stadion Thomas gulz danke schön
nach
Berlin Dänemark
überraschungseuropameister von 1992 hat
durch das 2:1 gegen Slowenien vorzeitig
die Qualifikation für die emendrunde im
kommenden Jahr in Deutschland perfekt
gemacht und Albanien ist auch mit Hilfe
dieses meters von zokolikalesi zum
zweiten Mal in seiner Fußball chichte
dabei
entstand ein zu ein in der Republik
Moldau Albanien damit Tabellenführer
Polen kann dagegen nach dem
Unentschieden gegen die ebenfalls
qualifizierten Tschechen nur noch auf
die Relegation
hoffen der Südtiroler Tennisprofi
Jannick Sinner ist der erste Italiener
im Finale der ATP Finals nach dem
dreisitserfolg gegen den Russen daniil
medwedev trifft er morgen in Turin auf
Oldi dokovic oder Youngster
alkas Erfolg für bobpilot Johannes
Lochner auf der Olympiabahn von
2022 in janching gewinnt er nach dem
zweierwettbewerb auch das weltcupprennen
im Quartett vor Olympiasieger Francesco
Friedrich und Team zweier Bob
Weltmeister Johannes Lochner fährt zum
Auftakt des Weltcups in den Spuren
seines Idols Francesco Friedrich nach
dem Erfolg im Duett sichert sich Lochner
auf der Erfolgsbahn der deutschen auf
der Olympiabahn in Peking auf den
zweiten Weltcupsieg bin zwei Tagen
diesmal im
er untermauert damit die starke Form
seines Teams gegen den eigentlichen
Superstar Bob Francesco Friedrich der
kritisch ist ich glaub in der ein ist
wir so ein Biss dahintern sagen wir wie
auf gut deutsch abgerutscht und dann
nehmen wir den Schwung nicht mit und
müssen uns in der Bahn ranarbeiten sind
so viele kleine Punkte Fazit in Peking
die Saison verspricht dan Lochner
spannende Zweikämpfe gegen den
bobdinator und viermaligen Olympiasieger
friedich ja Daumen hoch und Tschüss
dankeön es bleibt nass mit Schauern aber
auch etwas mehr Sonne mehr dazu gleich
von östtin terli um 11:15 Uhr begrüßt
Sie Christian sieers im heutejournal wir
wünschen noch ein schönes Wochenende bis
morgen wenn Sie mögen auf
[Musik]
Wiedersehen schönen guten Abend und
herzlich willkommen zum Wetter ja das
Regengebiet das liegt schon wer über
Deutschland und verlagert sich nun
allmählich ostwärts was wir hier noch
erkennen ist morgen im Tagesverlauf
lockert es hier auf sehen die grünen
Flächen und das scheint mal die Sonne
aber sehen auch noch weiterhin blaue
Sprenkler und das sind die Schauer die
sich im Tagesverlauf bilden es wird aber
nicht ganz so trüb sein wie heute im
Tagesverlauf es war wir schauen in die
Nacht und da wird es dicht bewölkt sein
mit viel Regen und anfangs der Nacht in
den höheren Lagen auch mit Schnee im
Nordwesten gibt's dazu Blitz und Donner
mit tief tiefsten Temperaturen von -1°
im Osten und 8° ganz im Westen
Deutschlands und morgen zieht der Regen
im Osten ab im Süden ziehen sich die
Regenwolken an die Alpen zurück
dazwischen gibt's immer wieder
Sonnenschein aber dann bilden sich auch
Schauer und das bei höchsten
Temperaturen von 9 bis 14 teils 15° im
Südwesten Deutschlands also ziemlich m
die nächsten Tage am Montag im Norden
vor allem viel Regen 7 bis 12° Dienstag
wird's Kühler ja und mit w nur noch ein
bis 7° aber mit deutlich mehr
Sonnenschein und damit einen schönen
Abend